hola a todos bienvenidos a esta emisión
especial de economía en france 24
yo soy daniel hablando ahora
analizaremos lo que fue el año más
crítico en la historia mundial reciente
la economía sufrió los embates de la
crisis sanitaria originada por el kobe
de 19 pero también interminables guerras
comerciales y una agitada salida del
reino unido- de la unión europea
empezamos con la que es sin duda la
noticia del año la pandemia del
coronavirus una crisis sanitaria que
rápidamente se volvió económica la
llegada del virus a cada rincón del
planeta borró años de crecimiento y
sumergió al mundo en una recesión con
pocos precedentes en la historia
una crisis mundial como la actual no se
veía desde hace décadas
las campana de los últimos meses se ha
vuelto más terrible sin embargo seguimos
proyectando la peor recesión mundial
desde la gran depresión
station since the great presión no hay
un país que pueda decir que ha salido
ileso ni siquiera china que se encamina
a ser la única gran economía que se ve
el lujo de crecer en 2020 pues su
producto interno bruto llego a ser
negativo este año por primera vez desde
1992 pero los expertos coinciden en algo
américa latina es la región más
damnificada
en 2019 el pib regional se salvó por
unos cuantos dólares de contraerse
república dominicana guatemala y
colombia tomaron la delantera mientras
venezuela nicaragua y argentina ya
venían mal antes de que apareciera el
coronavirus las proyecciones de la cepal
para este año apuntan a que las
economías que enfrentarán los más
oscuros panoramas son venezuela perú
panamá argentina y méxico que tienen
casi asegurada una contracción mayor que
la del resto de la región las heridas
que más tardarán en sanar son las del
empleo
chan grades esta pandemia ha generado
una crisis económica y social una crisis
laboral de proporciones sin precedentes
y un tipo de weiss tres jóvenes se han
visto muy afectados como siempre han
sido expulsados de la fuerza laboral más
que otros sabemos que aquellos que salen
de la universidad ahora enfrentan
expectativas más sombrías para hacer esa
siempre difícil transición hacia el
mundo laboral weiss steve coach frank
sesión en to the world of work
la organización internacional del
trabajo estima que la pandemia ha
destruido lo equivalente a unas 500
millones de plazas laborales en todo el
mundo 34 millones en américa latina y el
caribe si en 2018 el 79 por ciento de la
fuerza laboral de la región se halló sin
empleo en 2020 se estima que será el 11
5% con un incalculable repunte en la
cifra de informales los organismos
internacionales no ven una recuperación
en el corto plazo en el mejor de los
casos que la actividad económica vuelva
a niveles pre pandémicos tomaría más de
dos años dependiendo del país y otro
tema que ocupó los principales titulares
económicos en 2020 fue el break sheet
reino unidos se unió en 1973 a la unión
europea en 2016 decidió abandonarla tras
de realizar un referendo entre sus
ciudadanos esta salida sólo fue posible
hasta el 31 de enero de 2020 ese día al
break si está apenas estaba comenzando
pues ese concreto la salida pero no cómo
iba a ser la nueva relación con el
bloque de los 27 que era
más difícil ahí se dio paso a lo que se
conoció como un periodo de transición
que iba hasta el 31 de diciembre de 2020
desde entonces iniciaron arduas
conversaciones para concretar un acuerdo
comercial finalmente alcanzado en las
horas previas a la nochebuena del 24 de
diciembre algo que desde octubre se
venía anticipando incluso en medio de la
incertidumbre sobre si iba a haber o no
consenso
es un acuerdo justo y equilibrado es un
testimonio de nuestro compromiso de
encontrar soluciones proporciona certeza
donde él preside en certidumbre protege
los derechos de nuestros ciudadanos así
como la paz y la estabilidad en la isla
de irlanda
andy creo que este acuerdo representa un
muy buen negocio tanto para la unión
europea comparada en unidos tenemos un
resultado razonable y todo refleja todo
el trabajo que han realizado ambas
partes
estoy muy de acuerdo jean claude con lo
que dice sobre la protección del proceso
de paz en la isla de irlanda e irlanda
del norte
este acuerdo evitó una salida británica
abrupta y traumática lo pactado dice que
no habrá aranceles ni cuotas en el
comercio entre las dos partes lo que sí
habrá es más burocracia para las
empresas ya que reino unido está
abandonando el mercado único y la unión
aduanera del bloque comunitario por
ejemplo las empresas deberán presentar
formularios y declaraciones de aduanas
también habrá diferentes reglas sobre
etiquetado de productos y controles
sobre productos agrícolas aunque uno de
los cambios más notables será en el
tránsito de personas que ya no será
libre las estancias superiores a tres
meses requerirán visas pero veamos que
ha sido lo que ha estado en juego en
esta relación que se rompe después de
casi cinco décadas
hablamos de dos bloques de peso muy
diferente la población de la unión
europea es de casi 450 millones de
habitantes mientras que la del reino
unido es el 6 veces menor
casi 67 millones ambos tienen un mercado
común de más de un billón de dólares al
año la unión europea es el principal
socio comercial de gran bretaña pues
representa el 45 por ciento de su
comercio total entre importaciones y
exportaciones
en cambio la dependencia de la unión
europea sobre el reino unido- es mucho
menor representa apenas el 13 por ciento
de su comercio lo más difícil en las
negociaciones fueron tres cosas las
normas sobre competencia los mecanismos
de resolución de conflictos y la pesca
en aguas británicas algo que londres ve
como un tema de soberanía más que
económico durante siglos hoy los
pescadores extranjeros compartieron las
abundantes aguas frente a gran bretaña
de ellas se benefician hoy países como
francia países bajos
irlanda y dinamarca reino unido a su vez
exporta el 80% de lo que pesca y casi
todo termina en la unión europea con el
acuerdo comercial firmado reino unido
cree que va a aprovechar más de sus
aguas
todo el tiempo que estuvimos en la unión
europea' hicimos parte de la política
pesquera común y eso fue una limitación
para nuestras comunidades costeras e
hizo que nuestra industria pesquera de
cayera en este momento en la unión
europea sólo podemos obtener
aproximadamente la mitad del pescado de
nuestras aguas en virtud de este acuerdo
aumentaremos esa cantidad a cerca de dos
tercios en unos pocos años pero las
guerras comerciales también fueron
protagonistas este año en enero de eeuu
y china firmaron un principio de acuerdo
que sirvió para mermar la hostilidad que
mantenían desde marzo de 2018 la casa
blanca mantuvo sus aranceles pero
beijing prometió comprar más productos
estadounidenses y aunque ambos se
comprometieron a avanzar a una siguiente
fase la pandemia del cob y 19 enfrío las
conversaciones chinas no subió sus
compras y las asperezas persisten como
lo explica nuestro invitado claudio
loser ex director para el hemisferio
occidental del fondo monetario
internacional
evidentemente ha habido un acuerdo
parcial entre estados unidos y china en
términos de comercio y hay digamos algún
tipo de regularización sin embargo en
los grandes temas eeuu ha mantenido su
nivel de protección respecto de muchas
importaciones de la china y la china
también ha puesto y ha mantenido
limitaciones en términos de inversiones
y en ese caso todavía no ha quedado
resuelto o sea que china pone
restricciones y así una empresa del
exterior puede tener digamos total
control sobre una inversión en la china
y eso no lo ha cambiado
donald trump es siempre ha visto en las
empresas chinas una gran amenaza para la
seguridad nacional
primero fue huawei y en 2020 tick tock
trump ha intentado por ahora sin éxito
presionar a la venta de las operaciones
de la red social en la comunidad
americana pero si en el frente chino la
batalla continúa por el lado europeo no
da tregua
eeuu y la unión europea llevan casi dos
décadas acusándose mutuamente de
subsidiar ilegalmente a sus gigantes
aeronáuticos boeing y hervás la
organización internacional del comercio
cree que ambos violaron las normas en
2019 autorizó a eeuu a imponer aranceles
hasta por 7.500 millones de dólares
anuales al grupo de los 27 las tarifas
afectaron desde los aviones hasta el
queso las aceitunas y los licores la
unión europea ganó la batalla más
reciente tras recibir 'luz verde' de la
omct impuso gravámenes a productos por 4
mil millones de dólares anuales que
incluyen desde tractores
dando por mariscos ginebra algodón y
hasta videojuegos este es un asunto que
seguramente tendrá ahora en su agenda el
nuevo jefe de la casa blanca
yo pienso acá es muy difícil leer
exactamente cómo se va a proceder dadas
las presiones que puede tener baile pero
claramente la presencia de baile y su
equipo económico que es un equipo mucho
más e internacionalista más interesado
en la cooperación internacional y no en
la visión transaccional de uno por uno
del presidente trump va a haber una
mejora importante en las relaciones con
europa eso es lo que se espera y en
otros temas que fueron noticia este año
en economía
el agua comenzó a cotizar en el mercado
de futuros de the wall street algo que
naciones unidas advierte que atenta
contra el derecho básico a su acceso y
que beneficiará a los especuladores
las multinacionales tecnológicas las
grandes beneficiadas de la pandemia
están en la mira de las autoridades
europa está discutiendo los impuestos
digitales y algunas de ellas como alfa
beta que es la matriz de google o
facebook enfrentan demandas
antimonopolio en eeuu
uva impulsó su reforma monetaria más
grande en décadas el país decidió
desaparecer el llamado peso convertible
que estuvo por casi tres décadas en
medidas anteriores el gobierno renunció
a su participación mayoritaria en
empresas mixtas y anunció que
privatizaría algunos restaurantes
estatales
y nuestra cifra del año tiene que ver
por supuesto con coronarios las
compañías farmacéuticas y
biotecnológicas son no sólo a manzana
ahora grandes fortunas de miles de
millones de dólares su precio en las
bolsas de valores ha subido en promedio
en un 20% este año hablamos de facer
variante que moderna y astrazéneca todas
valen en conjunto cerca de medio billón
de dólares en la bolsa de nueva york y
hace un año su valor conjunto sumaba a
poco más de trescientos mil millones de
dólares esto en esta especial de
economía recuerde que pueden seguir en
nuestra programación en nuestra página
web www punto frente 4 punto com y
también en nuestras redes sociales
[Música]